are you guys ready you guys ready hey
guys it's ink
so we've done these mixing everything
together videos before we've mixed every
cookie mix together every kind of cereal
together this time a days challenged me
to do the same thing but with cake makes
a lot of you have also been requesting
this in the comments also a lot of
youtubers I know have done this frame
before but today I'm gonna take on this
challenge and try to make it into the
most beautiful cake as I possibly can
I don't really know what that means I
know but we're gonna figure it out as we
go along so let's see what we're working
with okay first up we have red velvet
classic oh my god more gold and then we
have carrot cake healthier and then we
have lemon cake which I personally
really like another classic the white
cake mix chocolate fudge this one sounds
really good already I've actually never
had this before but this is strawberry
cake super pink party rainbow chip which
I guess is the same as like confetti
cake a yellow cake okay and then the
last one is devil's food cake
let me just rearrange this all right all
nine flavors of cake mix is here I'm
thinking we could mix them all together
and make it into one cake but that's
kind of boring and I don't know if it's
gonna taste good so I'm thinking I might
make a nine layer cake or actually maybe
a 10 layer cake because then for that
final layer we can mix all of them
together so this sound good
a ten layer cake okay so ten layer cake
it is let's get to mixing alright so we
have all the cake mixes lined up here
where's my whisk is just gonna toss
everything in so
two third cups of vegetable oil 1 cup of
water
beat vigorously by hand for two minutes
you know even when you mix it with other
flavors the cinnamon taste here is still
one that will break through no matter
what which is kinda nice and the Mon
that's like oh you get the yellow food
coloring now you see that yes oh no
that's not that's a yoke rainbow chip
this is a fun one you can already see
like the little funfetti bits inside so
that's fun
mmm chocolate brownies that's what we do
there brownies
Jimmy do brownies I don't know you guys
tell me look at how red this is looks
like a blood strawberry I would have had
this for my pink food challenge but I'm
pretty sure this is artificial pink okay
we have devil's food cake
yellow cake white cake chocolate fudge
carrot cake a lemon cake birthday cake
strawberry cake red velvet cake now I'm
thinking I'm gonna use this bowl and
take a little bit from each of these
cake mixes to make the ultimate cake
flavor
it could be ultimate good or ultimate
bad we'll find out
this is the white cake mix which would
help with the vanilla flavoring the
yellow cake mix which changes it in
color a little bit birthday cake mix
which is the fun confetti one lemon cake
which hopefully adds like a nice citrusy
touch strawberry
another foodie flavor adding some help
because we all need some carrots in our
lives devil's food first and then I'm
going to add the chocolate fudge last
scoop is our blood red red velvet cake
you know what time it is time to
sometime
oh boy who should I just leave it
marbled know I should mix it all
together marvel it would be cool but we
really want the flavors to kind of
integrate together the red is really
coming through wow I'm still confused it
just smells like cake we officially have
our 10 cake mixes now it's time to put
them into cake pans to get our 10 layers
wait wait before you do that I want to
taste it with it I'm so excited about
this and hopefully I don't get
salmonella here we go I think oatmeal
cookie I don't taste any chocolate
though really we'll see what happens
after you bake it yeah maybe I'll stay
stiffer n't ya
you're gonna pop this in the oven come
back finish the rest of them so the next
time you see me these will all be done
okay bye all right so cakes are all done
here are all ten of them I probably
shouldn't do that I feel like I'm gonna
drop him they came out okay not burnt
and kind of dome shapes I think now
though because we're gonna try to like
fill them up into layers I'm going to
use this cake leveler to sort of level
them off so then they're flat and they
won't become the Leaning Tower of Pisa I
have not done this before
I've actually never used a cake leveler
before so this is gonna be fun we waited
for all of them to cool before doing
this otherwise it would just be a
crumbly mess there we go
oh my god I almost killed it no okay
well here it is alright so now that we
have all the cakes leveled off I
actually ended up buying four different
types of frosting chocolate vanilla
cream cheese and this thing called
fluffy white that I've never seen before
but it looks like it could be fun I was
thinking why don't I mix all of these
frostings up to make a giant batch of
Franklin frosting okay thanks so hard to
pull up oh okay
oh this sounds so good can you guys tell
that I just really like chocolate I just
like chocolate oh my god Tower whoa do
you see that oh yeah that is super nice
I have the cake stand here I have my
cake board my palette knife I have not
actually done frosting like this before
in terms of layers and also just this
whole idea of crumb coating so a lot of
what I'm doing today I actually learned
from watching cupcake Gemma who
basically gave me my 101 on this so wish
me luck
I am going to put a little bit of
frosting on the cake board first to hold
the first piece of cake like so it's
sliding don't going to do a little bit
of crumb coating on this first crumb
coating really is to lock the crumbs in
so they're not like all over the place
now we're just gonna get a bigger
spoonful and just spread that on if I
accidentally tear any of this I have to
make it from the beginning all over
again
what's your place that there's no moving
it the frosting is so much like glue
you're okay you're okay
okay am i halfway there halfway there
this is the fifth layer so that's
exciting oh my god that almost fell
apart Lock them in wow I feel like I'm
getting lightheaded oh no is it tilting
again oh my god no don't fall this is
scary
we're so close please let me finish this
oh my god okay so we have a little
situation here where it is slightly
slanted I don't really know how to fix
that but I am going to try to now thrust
up the sides get that crumb coating in
lock it in and then hopefully frost it
properly I know I said the most
beautiful cake but in order to be
beautiful there are things you must do
first
I said I was making cake but it's really
just pottery
[Music]
okay if it falls it falls
[Music]
are you guys ready you guys ready
[Music]
that's pretty cool oh my god I didn't
fall over I'm so happy all right you did
it what do you think no it looks good
this is like beauty is in the eye of the
beholder and we are the V holders right
though no think this is much but you
turn it around and it's like boom so if
you want you can try a little bit of
that first and then maybe try it's got
it got it that's a lot going on I'm
tasting like Froot Loops
I'm tasting chocolate with cinnamon oh
but it still has that old meal taste
that I'm talking about you're saying if
you like try to scoop up a little bit
maybe I'm trying to get each piece there
we go this is a lot I get hit with like
one flavor and then I'm like oh it just
doesn't stop like I just keep getting
surprised and surprised but the frosting
I feel like the chocolate comes out the
most
it had the muscle the first flavor I got
when I first played in my mouth it was
women but then it was like flavors but
like flashes or flavors here and they're
very sweet cake okay a day what are you
gonna make me do next I don't know but
I'm gonna keep searching the internet
guys leave messages and suggestions in
the
you need to figure out what challenge to
stumped inca with until then we're just
gonna keep eating this ten layer cake
and you're eating eaten finishes cake
yeah can I have another piece yeah
[Music]